our commencement speaker was born in
Sussex which is in the setting southern
part of England where the son sends
three four days a month he has this
degrees from Oxford and Cambridge and
st. Andrews he has studied language and
literature and he has studied theology
and divinity he's a a distinguished
academic he's been a chaplain at a
Cambridge College he teaches at Houston
Baptist now sometimes and in Cambridge
sometimes his resume is in your program
your thought I want to say about him
there are controversies all over the
world today about very fundamental
things it's one of those times what do
we mean when we use the basic terms what
do we mean by good what do we mean by
nature what it would mean by family what
do we mean by anything what does
anything mean does it have a meaning
what do we mean by God today there's an
open debate about the extent of
religious freedom in America and of
course our College is founded in 1844
with a commitment to the inestimable
blessings of civil and religious liberty
and that is America's central idea the
first implement in the world to be born
that way and now we debate the extent of
it and many claims are made that it is a
dangerous and an unworthy thing and so
in such a time is that it matters so
much if somebody knows about God can
think about him and argue about him and
explain about him and I think the
greatest to do that in the 20th century
was the great CS Lewis and I think that
his greatest student although he never
knew CS Lewis judging by a book that
he's written about them that about him
that's called planet Narnia that is a
tour de force it's just an awesome piece
of work I think this man is the greatest
student of CS Lewis and he's here with
us today
he's taught on the campus before a lot
of us know him and are very proud to do
that and it is then a joy to me to
present to you Michael ward
Thank You president our class of 2015
honored guests faculty members of the
Board of Trustees of Hillsdale College
I bring you cordial greetings from your
erstwhile colonial overlords I bear
warmest felicitations from Her Majesty
the Queen professor Stephen Hawking from
James Bond Sherlock Holmes and the
entire cast of Downton Abbey
now I think that covers all the
important people in England I on the
other hand and distinctly unimportant so
I'm all the more grateful for the
invitation to be part of this very
special day thank you for having me it's
a great honor I only hope I can say
something worthy of the occasion and I
must say this before I say anything else
congratulations class of 2015
I know I know you will on this day above
all days be richly appreciative of all
the good things Hillsdale has given you
however it's been drawn to my attention
that there is one thing in which
Hillsdale is seriously deficient that
there is a strikingly in adequate
attention given here to the life and
work of Winston Churchill and I thought
I would remedy that situation by quoting
some of Churchill's most famous words
they seem apt for this ceremony this is
not the end it is not even the beginning
of the end but it is perhaps the end of
the beginning so today you move from the
end of your beginning to the start of
your commencement I come from the old
world and in particular from Oxford the
home of lost causes
where we don't have something called
commencement we just graduate and
diminish and go into the west and remain
embittered so America's status as the
home of fresh starts of the pioneering
spirit of beginnings leading to
commencements that all sounds to us
alarmingly positive and energetic
someone once remarked that if you
combined British pessimism with American
optimism
you got divine realism well maybe this
is why Churchill with his British father
and his American mother is such an
Olympian figure and I'll be returning to
Churchill at the end of my talk but this
is not yet the end of my talk it is not
even the beginning of the end
but it is perhaps the end of the
beginning you're about to graduate from
a most remarkable institution I first
came to Hillsdale 14 years ago I was
meant to visit for just four days but
ended up staying for eight they'll
explain that later you have come for
four years and if any of you have stayed
for eight very special congratulations
to you today since that first visit I've
returned several times I've addressed
groups of Hillsdale students in England
I've become good personal friends with a
number of Hillsdale professors and
graduates and even had the privilege of
conducting the wedding of a former
Hillsdale student so I think I know
Hillsdale well for an outsider but I
know other colleges in America - I've
been to nearly 40 of the 50 states in
the Union where I've spoken at their
better part of a hundred educational
institutions including Harvard Yale
Princeton Chicago and Stanford so I
think I'm in quite a good position to
compare and when in the past I've made
such comparisons I must say Hillsdale
students have always struck me that's it
they've always struck me they just come
up and hit me
maybe it's the cod Churchill
impersonation but no seriously Hillsdale
students have always struck me as having
a unique quality to them and what is
this unique quality I've often tried to
work out what it is and writing this
commencement speech has given me a good
excuse to consider the question in more
depth
Hillsdale isn't the oldest college in
America though it lacks not for
historical sense and all that's best in
the classical tradition hills dales not
the biggest college though it's building
stock has been considerably enlarged and
beautified in the years I've been coming
and I look forward to seeing the new
Chapel in due course Hills Dale's not
the richest college though I understand
that capital campaign has been going
well so well that president arm can
expect to be contacted soon by the
patent attorneys of King Midas Hillsdale
is not the most famous college though
perhaps some of you here today will
eventually make it so in a good way so
if it's not the oldest the biggest the
richest or the most famous where else
could Hillsdale special quality possibly
lie well only in the most important
thing namely its ability to produce
quality of mind students here have a
quality of mind that I've simply not
encountered in the same way so reliably
elsewhere but what do I mean by quality
of mind to help answer Bert I turn to
the writer whom I've made a special
study of CS Lewis who in his article
willing slaves of the welfare state
writes this I believe a man is happier
and happy in a richer way if he has the
freeborn mind but I doubt whether he can
have this without economic independence
which the new society is abolished
for economic independence allows an
education not controlled by government
and in adult life it's the man who needs
and asks nothing of government who can
criticize it's axe and snap his fingers
at its ideology read Montaigne that's
the voice of a man with his legs under
his own table eating the mutton and
turnips raised on his own land thus CS
Lewis very applicable to Hillsdale and
if dr. Arnn in this picture is Montaigne
and the table is the college that makes
you class of 2015 the mutton and the
turnips I think we must allow for a
certain hyperbole in what Lewis says
when he talks of the man in adult life
who needs and asks nothing of government
I doubt such a person really exists all
of us need something from the government
working sewerage roads to drive on
armies to defend us but if we understand
Lewis to be talking about education pure
and simple as I believe he is then we
can see the truth and the importance of
what he says an education not controlled
by government nor even influenced by
government allows for the Freeborn mind
allows for doesn't automatically and
necessarily provide the Freeborn mind
one can still be servile and indentured
in other ways shackled by the zeitgeist
for instance or subject to party pre but
if a college is economically independent
of the government well there are just
certain things its members needn't be
cowed by one is liberated from a
cupboard loved one is no longer
conditioned to salivate like a Pavlovian
dog when a fashionable pedagogical bell
is rung you can make your own mind up if
you think the government's wrong you can
snap your fingers
if you think the government's right you
can tip your hat but you're not
enthralled you've severed the chains of
economic dependency and assumed the high
dignity of someone who's educationally
free born in my interactions with
Hillsdale students I have witnessed this
capacity for free thinking free thinking
in the best sense thinking that's free
not because its anarchic or tradition
less but because it's untrammeled yet
responsible and humane now I dare say
that during the last four years as
you've gone about earning the
qualifications you'll receive your to
receive today you quite possibly haven't
given a whole lot of thought to the
quality of your mind and if that's the
case I say so much the better you've
been exercising your Liberty not
thinking about it and by highlighting it
today I don't mean to turn you all into
narcissists it's the invalid the
hypochondriac who's forever thinking
about and fetishizing his health the
healthy person just gets on and lives a
healthy life so if you've been enjoying
the Liberty of Hillsdale without often
reflecting upon how it gives your mind a
certain tone well that's right and
proper and it's a wonderful thing to see
students breathing the clean air of
intellectual Liberty there's a dignity
even a nobility about students who've
been formed in this way and I hold this
mirror up to you today not so you may
become vain but in order that you may
catch a glimpse however brief of your
own intellectual shapeliness and give
thanks for it whenever you eat mutton or
turnips think of this and then get
straight back on with living your life
my first charge to you then normally
your the charges but today your the
charge
my first charge to you is simply this
rejoice rejoice in the freedom of
Hillsdale College and in what it's made
possible for you and through you for
others you're a shining example of what
it can mean to be free born you hold up
a light illuminating a whole way of
being in the world that's always been
needed always will be needed and is
perhaps needed now more than ever if
America is a beacon of political freedom
to the world
Hillsdale is a beacon of educational
freedom to America it's a college set on
a hill in the city set on a hill and
this brings me to the second thing I
want to say don't worry there are only
two things I want to say this is not the
end but it is the beginning of the end
my second point has to do with hills
dales name I first heard the name
Hillsdale in 2001 when an Oxford friend
of mine dr. Andrew kunio was appointed
here as an English professor I remember
being immediately intrigued by Hillsdale
from a purely filler logical point of
view did the Dale belong to the hill I
wondered was there a possessive
apostrophe in there somewhere
was it one particular Hills Dale or were
there two or more Hills with one Dale
somewhere in between them the more I
mulled over the word the more I liked it
it was something of an oxymoron oxymoron
not Oxford [ __ ]
oxymoron means literally a sharp fool
and you know the standard examples of
oxymorons
bittersweet deafening silence open
secret pretty ugly jumbo shrimp
journalistic integrity burek
bureaucratic efficiency governmental
restraint French intelligence American
culture British humility so in the
months when my friend dr. kunio was
preparing to leave Oxford and come to
Hillsdale I kept saying to him where are
you going again
what's this College called Peaks Vail
heads tail tops bass tips Pitts I was
particularly pleased with the tip spit
because that's a palindrome as well as
an oxymoron and I was all the more
intrigued by the name because it had a
certain resonance with the great novel I
wrote in the years after I graduated
when I say I wrote this great novel I
don't mean it was ever published
nor that it was ever really written but
it was extensively imagined as a 22 year
old graduate in English I thought I was
ideally equipped to write the next great
British novel and I spent two and a half
years trying and failing to do this and
my story was said this is God's own
truth my story was set in an English
village called tor de la tour of course
meaning a cracked or a rocky peak now
there is no actual place in England
called tor Dale
it was the inventing of my own pure
brain but I made the name up because I
thought it would be a subtle yet very
profound symbolic way of suggesting one
of the great themes of the novel which
was that the highest doesn't stand
without the lowest the head cannot say
to the foot I have no need of thee the
scriptural epigraph behind the whole
work was going to be Psalm 95
or in his hand are the depths of the
earth
a strength of the hills is his also and
this theme was of some personal
significance to me because I was finding
in those years immediately after
graduation that I'd gone from the
heights to the depths I had had a
glorious undergraduate experience at
Oxford I loved my subject I did well
academically I made great friends I
enjoyed sport and music and drama and
church life it was everything that Jude
the Obscure could have wanted my best
pal and I would sometimes crystals
crystallized this happiness by saying ah
jolly Oxford days as if we were already
octogenarians summoning up remembrance
of things past and then it all ended and
I was back home living with my
long-suffering parents the opportunities
and stimulation of college life suddenly
withdrawn relatively few friends having
to come gradually to terms with the fact
that I wasn't going to be the next great
British novelist in those two and a half
years I earned precisely 250 pounds from
my pen fifty pounds every six months it
was a regular income but it was a major
come down and I think quite a lot of
people find the years straight out of
college to be some of the hardest in
life all the educational framework which
you've used to hold yourself up and
which in large part you have defined
yourself by is taken away and you're
like a climbing rose without a trellis
and you either lie on the ground and rot
or allow yourself to be pruned and gets
turned into a rosebush that can stand in
in its own integrity
well I rotted for a while and became
fairly depressed
won't pretend otherwise but then thank
God that mysterious thing happened but
the psalmist mentions in Psalm 84 when
he speaks of the man who going through
the veil of misery makes it into a well
you lie there in this veil of misery
hitting your head on the ground and
slowly you become aware that the water
collecting there isn't just made up of
your own hermos self-pity there's a
fresher source of water - this was a
mysterious moment of spiritual and
psychological growth for me but not one
I'll dwell on here because this is after
all a commencement address not a sermon
suffice it to say from that point on
things began slowly to improve I don't
mean that I jumped straight out of the
trough and shot up the greasy pole of
success again nor that I just exchanged
low spirits for high spirits
I began rather to realize that hill and
dales there are equally imposters like
Kipling's triumph and disaster success
can't keep its promises and failure
can't hold its ground one shouldn't be
bamboozled by either state the important
thing is not to be in a certain state
but to be a certain kind of person in
whichever state you find yourself sure I
think one has a duty to do as much as
one can to fulfill one's potential to
strive for success certainly to do good
and avoid evil but the outcome of one's
efforts is of secondary importance to
quote a certain Wizards advice to a mr.
Underhill significant name he was
lamenting that he lived in dark days all
we have to decide is what to do with the
time that he's given us
or as Mother Teresa said we are not
called to be successful we are called to
be faithful I mention all this so you
don't set too much store by the little
biography about me that you may have
read in today's program
remember commencement speakers are
invited when they're on the rise or
enjoying a mountaintop view
rarely when they're on the way down or
in the dumps but they know the dumps but
all this is by way of explaining the
sudden delight I felt when I discovered
that the fictional town of my own
inventing toward ale had a counterpart
in reality in the great state of
Michigan I was genuinely intrigued and I
seized the opportunity to come and as I
mentioned my first visit to Hillsdale
was meant to be only four days in
duration it turned out to be eight why
well I arrived here on the 10th of
September 2001 I'm staying with my
friend Andrew kunio and on the 11th of
September he brought me onto campus at
about 9:00 in the morning
we walked into Delp where his office was
and one of his colleagues dr. Somerville
greeted us and happened to mention some
troubling news out of New York that he
just heard something about a plane and
the World Trade Center the rest of that
terrible day unfolded and brought a
ghastly timeliness to the lecture I was
preparing to give here at Hillsdale on
CS Lewis's responses to war it was a
truly shocking event an epoch defining
event in the course of a morning the
whole international outlook was plunged
into crisis that clear blue September
sky was suddenly a cloud of dust and ash
and so if my first charge to you is to
rejoice in the light and air on the
hilltop of Liberty my second charge is
to take heart when faced with the valley
of Tears
whether that Valley be god forbid a grim
and grave reversal like that suffered by
so many at the center of 9/11 or a
comparatively trivial setback like the
doldrums I found myself in personally
after graduating you'll all have
experienced many a low point in the
course of your life already I doubt not
so I'm not saying anything you don't
already know but if my own experience is
anything to go by there's a step change
once you're out of college because as I
say the whole framework of your life is
now different now it's much more up to
you
or should I say down to you how you
respond how you forge a path through
this life that's what caught me out for
a while soon after I graduated I wish
someone had warned me of it perhaps they
did and I just didn't listen but I can
at least try to pass on to you what it
is what seems no one told me and I say
this not to depress you but to
four-armed you should you need for
arming at graduation I thought I had
arrived having done all I was told I
should accomplish by way of earning a
good degree from a good school I thought
I could expect life to unfurl smoothly
before me in a series of ever more
pleasant and successful scenes it took
me quite a while to realize that this
wasn't to be my lot this is a lot of
nobody and that life actually proceeds
according to what CS Lewis calls the law
of undulation GK Chesterton called it
the rolling English Road Winston
Churchill's life is a particularly
striking example of the law of
undulation this rolling English road not
only because his was a very long and
very public life but because its heights
and its depths where it were of
extraordinary amplitude a happy marriage
with five children but to pre deceased
him
a glittering early career marred by the
Dardanelles restoration to political
prominence but then the wilderness years
the immortal triumph of his combat with
Hitler followed by summary expulsion
from national office and many other ups
and downs besides but one of the things
I admire about Churchill is that he
didn't just let these things happen to
him his life may have been a roller
coaster but he was more than a mere
passenger he knew that the wise man
learns from his reverses he doesn't just
defy them he turns them to effect
Churchill responded to the low points in
his life with the muscle of his will yes
but also with the artistry of his soul
and I think we see a nice illustration
of this in his passionate interest in
painting if you haven't read his
painting as a pastime do it's one of the
great things that he wrote he took up
painting during the Great War and I have
the sense that painting for him was more
than I more than just a diverting hobby
more than a release valve from the
pressures of high office it was also a
way in which he could respond creatively
artistically to difficulty transmuting
it into something noble and beautiful
the white canvas didn't simply offset
the black dog no the white canvas became
an opportunity for him to represent
visually in color and in contrast a
unified perception of diverse reality he
painted almost all his canvases in oils
and though he naturally inclined towards
the brighter colors in his palette and
felt he said genuinely sorry for the
poor Browns he knew that all landscapes
possess darkness as well as light even a
still life require
shadows sheer contrast mere black
against mere white matte depicts nothing
of interest there must be engagement
between the two and a shattering of the
white light into the full chromatic
spectrum when Churchill first began to
paint he found himself more engaged with
reality looking at things a fresh with
new attentiveness with greater
intelligence a richer integration
he wrote this one is quite astonished to
find how many things there are in the
landscape that one never noticed before
so many colors on the hillside each
different in shadow and in sunlight
burst Churchill and from genuine
Churchill to more Cod Churchill this is
not the start it is not even the
conclusion of the start but it is
perhaps the start of the conclusion and
what is my conclusion simply this class
of 2015 rejoice in the strength of the
hills take courage in the depths of the
earth Godspeed